We previously
discussed the concept
of conservation of momentum.
We will soon see that there
is another very powerful
conservation principle
in physics called
the conservation of energy.
It states that there is a
certain quantity called energy
that remains unchanged
in the system
except for any that flows
in or out of the system.
It's hard to say
exactly what energy is.
It's an abstract quantity that
we count up in a certain way.
When calculating the
energy of a system,
we must keep careful
track of any energy that
enters or leaves the system.
There are also a number
of different forms
of energy-- kinetic energy,
gravitational energy,
elastic energy, electrical
energy, heat energy,
and others.
Each of these has its own
formula for calculation.
If you sum all these
energies up for a system,
the total will remain
unchanged except for what
goes in and comes out.
It turns out that using
energy rather than force,
one can construct a
complete system of mechanics
that is fully equivalent
to the Newtonian system.
This was done by
Lagrange and Hamilton.
And you may encounter
their system in the future,
if you take more advanced
courses in physics.
However, even in the
Newtonian system,
energy remains a useful concept.
This week, we will
discuss kinetic energy,
the energy associated
with the motion of a mass,
and also the concept
of work, which
allows us to calculate
how the action of a force
changes the kinetic energy.
We will see that the
work done by a force
is calculated by
evaluating an integral that
in general depends upon the
specific trajectory or path
taken by the object or system.
However, we will also
see that there [? is ?]
a special class of forces called
conservative forces for which
the work integral
is path independent
and instead depends only on
the starting and ending points.
Finally, we will
discuss examples
of both conservative and
non-conservative forces.